planning committee
um a gender item one chairman's notices
two very short ones recording of the
meeting please note that the council
will be recording and publishing on the
council's website any part of this
meeting held in open session
and while i talk about this can you
please members can you please realize
that when you speak you need to have a
microphone close to you or you will not
be recorded and heard
the second notice this fire in the end
in the event of a fire officers will
notify those present please use the fire
exit marked with the green running man
which is at the back of the room the
fire assembly point is barclays bank car
park please gather there and await
further instruction
uh gender item two apologies for absence
i believe we've got councillor schemes
and councillor boyce
as apologies yes chairman that's right
thank you
agenda item three minutes of the last
meeting found on pages seven to twelve
did everybody agree that
you weren't here no that's right but
apart from that
everybody agrees it thank you very much
gender item for
disclosure of interests
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph nine
and appendix b of the code of conduct
for members and members are reminded
that they are also required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting and while i'm speaking
i would say that i
know the applicant of gender item seven
and i know the
applicant's agents for both seven
and eight
any other members
council mrs channer
thank you
um
seven and number
is
okay anybody else
in that case we will
move on to agenda item five
[Music]
and we're at primly lodge grange road
tillingham
it's one of two for the same site and
it's a planning the first one's a
planning application for the erection of
two polytunnels
an extension of an existing outbuilding
for storage and workshop in respect to
the horticultural and forestry use of
the land there's an office of
recommendation to approve and it is
before this committee due to the size of
the site i think it's about eight
um
um
um
uh
and trees
um
um
[Music]
within the site to be able to deliver
this so it's considered this provider's
adjustable and functional need for the
development
the proposal is also considered to be
directly linked to the cultural use of
the land um
the
[Music]
in this sort of um
any neighboring impacts could be managed
by conditions relating to any opening
hours and a noise management plan should
in the future begin to operate as a
that nurse operator
degrees impacts
economy and other cultural impacts can
also be dealt with by ways of conditions
which are
which have been approved conditions
okay thank you
i believe we have
by the wonders of modern science mark
jackson the agent for the applicant
joining remotely by uh microsoft teams
maybe we don't
good evening members uh mr jackson
you've got two minutes from the time you
start speaking
thank you very much
my name is mark jackson i'm a chartered
town planner i am instructed by the
applicant mr whitaker for the two
applications that land to the rear of
finley lodge
mr whitaker is a qualified ecologist and
the owner of the land
the land is a small holding with land
set aside for a woodland fruit orchard
bee hives and a flower meadow
these are horticultural activities
falling within the definition of
agriculture
the future proposals of the harvesting
of the wood crop the seed bank and the
growing and selling of herbs and sapling
trees
this application seeks planning
permission to erect two polytunnels and
to extend one of the existing buildings
to provide a permanent store the
applicant's tools and equipment to
support the horse cultural and forestry
use of the land
officers recommend the application be
approved subject to the imposition of
twelve conditions
they're on pages 25-27 of your agenda
planning permission is not required for
the use of the land for horticulture and
forestry the polytunnels will be used
for the growing of tree saplings and
herbs
the extension of the outbuilding will
replace the container to provide a
secure building for tools and equipment
to maintain the land
the store is to be finished in timber
where the board tunnels in polythene
sheeting these are normal structures and
buildings within an agricultural area
the buildings will be in keeping with
the countryside character we agree with
the officers that the proposals are
acceptable in principle and matters of
landscape residential immunity access
impacts on ecology trees the plot risks
are all acceptable members are
respectfully requested to grant planning
permission subject to conditions thank
you thank you very much
um
i don't really have anything much to say
on it except that it has
about this site there's been a
considerable amount of social media
discussion about it
and there's a lot of misunderstanding
and the owner of primly lodge is not the
owner of this land but apart from that
um it's completely separate and
apartment i don't have any objections to
it so any other members
thank you very much
agenda item six
same site retrospective planning
application
section 73a for the change of use of
land for the sighting of a storage
container
in respect to the horticultural and
forest reuse of the land and the
provision of a hard surface track
uh again recommendation to approve by
officers
um
um
uh
um
so the as with the previous application
it's reasonable to expect the use of the
site to require equipment and machinery
in order to operate and reasonably
secure
locations
the existing buildings aren't considered
conditions
use
there would be some visual harm
resulting from the track um
agriculture and forestry production the
level of harm resulting from the track
is considered to be outweighed by the
needs and benefits of the proposal
the container is well streamed and
in 12 months is although it isn't
necessarily attractive development
impacts would be short-term
um again we have mr jackson who
i assume wants to speak for two minutes
he is on the list to do so mr jackson
you're two minutes
thank you chairman
the applicant had cited the container to
secure his equipment and tools
he also laid gravel onto an existing
track
mr whitaker assumed planning prevention
was not required and officers invited
him to make a retrospective application
the temporary consent of 12 months is
sought for the container
the cana container is in the position of
a former building
the application is supported by a flood
risk assessment ecology report tree
report letter from the applicant and
myself and design and access statement
the officer's recommendation to the
committee is to grant planning
permission subject to a condition that
the container is only retained for 12
months on page 39 of your agenda
we agree with the officers that it is
reasonable for the applicant to have a
secure store and the gravel surface is
important to be able to access and
manage the horticultural activity
matters of landscape residential
immunity access impacts on ecology trees
and flood risks are all acceptable
members are respectfully requested to
grant planning permission thank you
thank you mr jackson
again i have no comment to make on this
recommendation can we cancel mr stamp
certainly
sorry
has found that they're not high quality
trees
will
be there
i don't think
impact on the ability
uh
agreed
thank you
the gender item
seven
agenda item seven is lost
loftman's farm malden road steeple
construction of a two-story detached
dwelling and change of land used to see
three
it's with before us as a member calling
from cancer mr channel
but there's an officer recommendation to
refuse
the
images
it's also considered that the proposal
would harm the character appearance of
the science landing area
and the application
lacks sufficient information in relation
to the impact on protecting priority
species
thank you very much
we have one
member of the public who wishes to
partake and participate in this and
that's the applicant stephen massenhove
this person if you could step forward
get somewhere near that microphone
and you've got
two men
[Music]
you've got two minutes from the time you
start speaking and you will be stopped
at the end of that
these buildings
is
in all is to be on site
most of the time these weeks have got
something exceptionally challenging
working maintaining a phone like this is
very
ownership of consuming advance is much
later than previous generations but in
our situation it's not an option to
relocate our mother at this time so the
second dwelling on the property is
thank you very much
sorry
board members
board members mr channel do you wish to
speak on this
um
is
you need to be on site
this application is a market dwelling
it's not an agricultural workers
dwelling so the points in relation to
the need for an agricultural business
shouldn't be of material consideration
and termination applications it's not in
front of the committee outside of what
we've just heard it's not a form of
submission
thank you
information for that consideration but
that information isn't for the committee
so shouldn't be given any way in the
termination of this application
um
relation to employment is that there is
a need for evidence based before we
release it this application has got no
evidence with it it'd be a very
dangerous decision i'd advise the
committee to ever look to accept
any application for almost anything
where there was a requirement for a
certain level of information and that
has not been accepted because that would
become a material situation in any
future applications thank you sharon
any other members
councils
[Music]
for 10
um
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
in addition to the building the dwelling
already on site and i'm going to
understand possibly a technical staff
carried out
and perhaps
northwest committee
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you chairman
committee will be aware i've got no
ability to answer any of those points on
those applications because i'm not aware
of the whole decision making process
about the application over the last so
many years
as always i advise if members have
questions like that please let us know
in advance so we can provide you with
the accurate information
um unfortunately i can't answer any of
that what i would say obviously is as
always each applications term in its own
merits i do accept our decisions our
material situations and precedence um i
gathered from the what counselor channel
saying a number of those applications
have appeared to have tied into
commercial premises and i would assume
that that was an argument was put
forward by the applicant as highlighted
already by myself this isn't as part of
this application and if the applicant
does want to push that forward as an
agricultural worker's dwelling or a
requirement for the profession for the
function of another business that should
be dealt with as a separate application
because at the moment this is just a
standalone application there is no
agricultural requirement there would be
no ability to tie it into the premises
and it could be granted permission today
sold tomorrow without there being any
need or any time which will be very
different to when there's no work
dwelling or a personal permission per se
but i said none of that's in front of
the council um
also in relation to the rams payment as
members notes i've said it many times
and same with any section 906 it's best
practice that you're putting a reason
for refusal until you have if you do not
have a sign of such 106 there may well
be a willingness to enter into that but
there is a financial cost of the
applicant there is a need for us to
check it etc it's not good use of
council resources to you know validate
these things and spend time on things
when it is uh something that you know an
application is going to be refused
anyway and it'll be no different so for
example if we refuse a scheme of a
hundred houses with their sex 106 is
just best practice that forms a reason
for refusal irrespective of whether or
not the applicant is willing to enter
into it and that's why the wording of
the
reason for views was the way it is
rather than being the applicant will not
or something
unless anybody's got a different
proposal there is an officer
recommendation to
refuse is that seconded
in that case somebody better come up
with something different
torn
[Music]
quite
um
um
is a very long second
the application itself is deemed to be
refused because it's an application for
a standalone dwelling is that what we're
looking at chairman um obviously there's
a number of reasons refusal one of them
is that this application is submitted as
a standalone dwelling none of that other
information has been present as part of
the applications consideration i'm not
going to comment one way or other about
any of that and because it would also
still need evidence and all those things
but the council does have policies that
support
rural
and
we would probably be
there hasn't been a vote on this one yet
so until that's done whatever might
happen in the future
but
anyway there is a office of
recommendation duly seconded to refuse
this those in favors of that please show
yes
and um
from the sound of things the applicant
might be advised to
have another look at it
[Music]
you were the only one that voted so it
was one vote to get it to get to get the
refusals
right
thank you members we'll move on
to gender item eight
hall meadows hall road ascheldum the
construction of a chalet-style rural
workers dwelling sorry cats mrs
come back
i'm afraid
uh
the gender item 8 whole meadows hall
road ashldum construction of a chalet
style rural workers dwelling
it's here by member calling councillor
fluker and
there's an officer recommendation to
refuse
um
in the
ownership
the proposals
so the application site is
located from services and facilities and
the application has not been supported
by sufficient information to justify
exceptional grant
planning the long-term viability
has not been demonstrated and the size
and scale of the dwelling is considered
to exceed what is
um we have one
person wishing to
speak on this and this is the agent of
the applicant mr
tony cousin if you'd like to get up and
come forward you know the rules you've
got two minutes to speak
thank you
who at that um
the previous officers
[Music]
is
is
um i as a board member i'll come back on
this later any other anybody else got
any
comments they wish to make cancer flu
for you called it in so yeah absolutely
and um
clearly there's a huge
um
um
um
commission was brought to this committee
um
the
business
um
there was a functioning business but
part of the application was that this
was being uplifted to actually be a
full-time commercial enterprise when
previously it hadn't been and that was
part of the argument as to why there was
a need for
overall
cultural workers dwelling
in policy application was granted a
temporary period of three years
as members i'm sure recall from january
um an extension was requested for three
years due to the fact that kazakhovic
the business has not been able to
perform
as of hoped
while the business you know appears to
be making some level of profit um it has
not been based on the evidence that was
submitted in january for the application
determined in january been functioning
as a full viable business for three
years that is what the council's policy
requires before we allow
a permanent agricultural worker's
dwelling
and that is the position of the policy
the information before us does not time
with that requirement and therefore
that's why the application is
recommended for refusal thank you
um
um
or activities associated with
agriculture
building businesses directly linked
ancillary to
the existing use
the building activity could not recently
located in
existing towns villages
um
is
um
and basically say it's not a sustainable
location now i'm not sure
you can't have this
is
seven times a day
seven days a week
so it's got a bus link
to south minister it's got a bus link to
tillingham but then
was to a light the d4 bus on one of
those eight occasions that he passes
and one could argue you could come back
and say well there is
it shows
um
before the d4 bus came and i mean with
fairness to officers
is
is the business sustainable i think
based on what's actually been going on
there i would say
yes it is
so
we've
um
staff members
it's
and everything else
and you can see that part of that
building the bottom
memories um
um
um
if members were
inclined to support my proposal then i
would ask that we make sure that says
mobile home is removed because i think a
lot of people locally would like to see
a mobile home
removed
and i think also gemini i think
um
um
anyone else interested should be able to
understand why
the members of the committee have gone
against officer's recommendation
obviously with reasons for a few so it's
quite clear because they're clear and
precise right obviously any member of
public was to look at what council
floofs
reason why the council has gone against
if it is approved uh against officer's
recommendation obviously that is what
needed but it might be helpful if i was
to make a few comments though before
um
obviously i'm totally about to bring up
most of the points which counts fluid
credits i said you know it's quite long
so hopefully i will be able to pick most
of them up um what i'd say in relation
to the reference inner policy e4 it's a
very perverse interpretation of that
policy the policy very clearly talks
about employment opportunities about
buildings that relate to that the policy
in relation to agricultural workers
dwellings is clearly age seven it
specifically states that policy as we
all know the local plan should be ready
in the whole there's a need to
understand which policy is tied to which
requirements and
as discussed actually the last site and
there is a policy that does support
workers dwellings
and this application at this
site is actually benefited for that
twice now already for a temporary basis
um
i would
flag that but see some concerns and
saying that the business is already
viable if you know you look back
slightly
the figures
in um 2019 was 9 000 pounds you know
while there has been an increase and i
would not say it's not been a
substantial it has been a
substantial increase
you know the policy requires three years
of evidence of a functional business and
i would just have concerns about
watering down that approach that policy
because if we would consistently have
such a lower threshold that would become
outstanding
as i said you know
h7 is the relation
that we look for in relation to
agriculture workers dwelling um i would
be concerned if members would say the
site was sustainable um
and i don't disagree with cancer
people's point that if you're looking
for
a new dwelling in relation to a cultural
development it's probably not going to
be in sustainable location but that's
the reason why we have policy h7 that
allows for dwellings if you can prove
there is a functional need etc for that
so i think to try and argue that this is
sustainable because if it needs to be
nearing agricultural premises is
actually a little bit
counter-intuitive because the policy
actually allows for dwellings in
unsustainable locations and to argue
both sides of the coin isn't
particularly helpful um
as i pointed out with cancer channel i
would be very much helpful if as always
if members are going to start citing
other permissions that they let us know
so we can actually have some ability to
comment on them because you know
unfortunately i don't quite have an
encyclopedia knowledge of every
application that's improved since i've
been here and i as i always say that
members you know it's very helpful if
you're going to try and discuss previous
applications that you'd last know in
advance we can comment on them
um and also the only other point
two things once in relation to the need
there's that temporary
uh
property already granted on the site
council is not saying that there is not
a functional need for the premises on
site we've acknowledged that already
we're just saying that they haven't
evidenced the requirements that are
needed for our policy in relation to a
permanent dwelling yeah
prematurity and there's always as i'd
say members you know whether the parish
council do or don't object is not
material consideration it's the value of
the comments they make and i think a
couple of things chairman
i would just say under five one twenty
four
you did mention the first piece the
profit
tax year 2020 2021
had increased but it also says the next
paragraph down that the net profit again
for the taxpayer 21.22 has also
increased again so you do enact you do
in effect have three years worth of
accounts which considering the extremely
difficult times that everybody
experienced from
beginning of 2020 up until fairly
recently i would have thought was pretty
good going via chairman as explained at
the time the last application the full
livery hasn't actually been up and
running at that time that was the
submission
yeah that was that submission of the
applications granted in 2021 i can only
quote what the applicant has said
themselves
that they're proposing to run has not
been functioning for seven years
first three years
and i'm trying to read this
this is
mrs stamp then cancer helmet
and i think that the business
um
tonight
i think we should move on to a vote
we've got a proposal
in the name of councillor
seconded by council mr stamp to
not agree the officer recommendation to
refuse but to approve the application uh
for the reasons given to
mr lee
those in favor of that please show
one two three four five six uh any
against
in that case
conditions
standard conditions
rather than trying to agree on the
conditions right now
if
i'd like to just say one thing because
it's come up in a couple of places the
office has brought it up first it was
mentioned again
i don't understand why there should be a
size for a rural workers dwelling rural
workers without families just the same
as anybody else i mean i am aware years
ago
of a not in this district and well out
of it but there was a planning officer
who would only agree to single bedroom
dwellings for agricultural workers now i
think that's morally and everything else
wrong
everybody's everybody's entitled to a
family through chairman um
it actually ties back to the old pps and
i can't what the letter is where
government guidance was very explicit
about the size and the functionality and
it sort of found its way into case law
and best practice that there needs to be
a functional need um and it's about
demand it's not about wants not about
desire and as members are sure you know
we've had plenty of uh
applications i dealt with over the years
where people have come to
remove agricultural workers dwelling
where the property is quite large and
there hasn't been anyone interested when
they've moved out so then we just end up
with a new large dwelling in of a market
dwelling in the country so i don't think
the point is these are supposed to be
functionally not exclusively you know at
no second has anyone said this needed to
be a one-bedroom dwelling but that's no
way
that's where it comes from it's
government guidance that's been around
for since probably before i was a
planner anyway yeah
right
gender item 9 any other items of
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent i don't
have any but somebody i do know wanted
to raise some point so i will bend the
rules
[Music]
thoughts i decided it might be better
not but i do think
it should be a formal decision it should
be a formal thing for
the directors to decide how it's going
to be done and it shouldn't involve
members i don't believe and
whether it should be burnham town
council it comes and opens up or whether
it
should be delegated to a member
[Music]
their problem it's down to it's down to
the directors to sort this one out
in record time but as it is we finish at
8 34. thank you members good night